oh I really have no time for cute clever
segues and speaking of that you know I'm
ask you when did it become wrong to
wanna cuddle you know when it when it
cutting become a bad thing I mean the
other night I was making love to a
prostitute yeah and and we get done
before I get done you know and but
that's that's just it I mean you know
that's it chief just gets up to leave
you know walks right out the door
you know walks right out the car door
and I'm like what about me that's you
know it's not what I paid for little
snuggle time maybe so uh I just saw the
movie Schindler's List and not that
funny really you know I I laughed maybe
ten times now yeah I recently attended a
prodrug rally in my basement
and it was good it was fun I like drugs
I'm a big fan
I am especially lucinda genex I love him
I think everybody should do him not all
at once not everybody all once I'd be a
bad thing but uh you know I think taking
responsibly and wisely they can be great
you know I believe that marijuana should
be legalized
really I do I mean you know under
certain conditions with with
restrictions I mean not everybody should
be able to get high whenever they want
that'd be a bad thing I mean I wouldn't
want my surgeon getting high right
before he operated yeah and really the
last thing I'd want to hear before I
went under would be yours give me one of
those pointy
[Music]
yeah yes thank you all right uh-huh okay
and and we are doing what here again
yeah you're right man this is good we
you know I mean that dad that'd be a bad
thing but I mean I should be able to you
know get high if I if I want if I come
home late and I just want to flip on the
channel see what new amazing discovery
there is I should be able to get high
and in my apartment you know without
having to go to jail and be anally raped
for ten years I think that's a thing
that's a bit harsh a penalty you know I
mean what's the worst thing that's gonna
happen you know I might have some sort
of you know baking accident baby but I
won't really cuz I'll be too high so
just call Domino's and that way you know
what kids working and somebody's gettin
employed and that's how capitalism works
in the country strong again the thing I
hate are these
the spokespeople for for the you know
probe legalization of marijuana
campaigns they're always idiot so the
ones you see interviewed on CNN he's
like ageing Grateful Dead hippie guys
it's very hard to take seriously
somebody who's wearing granny glasses
and a fez you know and they're out there
spouting all this misinformation they
look like cartoons or sitting there
going okay first of all marijuana should
be legalized and hemp should be
legalized because there are thousands of
reasons to use it because their usages
that you can use hemp seed and hemp oil
right to you can
you can make a rope right and you know
um that the Declaration of the
Constitution was signed on half man and
is they don't want you to know that man
they don't they're CNN they're trying to
make you because they don't want you to
think we their third eye man they're
trying to damn make you put a cap on
your third eye you know and Ted Turner
man I'm talking to you mother Crocker
because you know seriously you know I
mean you know cuz third ice like a
window that you just open it up and see
things for you unlatch it and wait you
don't even use a latch you use one of
those old it's the kind where you had
the crank and it comes out this way so
you can wash it from then alright here's
another fact did you know that over
forty seven percent of people who use
marijuana do so and that's the truth man
we'll be right back